I think the European Union is superbly
positioned to become a major player in
the 21st century.
Um,
and it has done quite well.
Uh,
the common currency,
uh,
the,
centralization necessary centralization
coordination through European law,
European courts,
um,
have done a great deal of good to the
continent that was divided.
Uh,
so along I think Europe faces two
fundamental challenges that are very
hard to overcome.
The first challenge is the demographic
challenge and gray and continent,
um,
Europe is growing much faster than the
United States is.
And so Europe has to deal with that
problem.
Uh,
that means that not only there are more
people who want to retire and,
uh,
and get up state pension.
That means that every year you have
about 2 million people that are missing
in the workforce because they retire and
you need to replenish them.
Um,
2 million,
that means 2 million immigrants from
somewhere.
Uh,
there isn't a country close to Europe,
large enough to supply to a million
immigrants a year,
let alone the,
the question of cohesion of integrating
these people into the European culture.
So Europe has in faces a huge challenge,
uh,
much more so than the United States do.
You had a challenge,
of course is.
Um,
and that's the beauty of the United
States.
The beauty of the United States is that
it,
it pushes itself to the brink,
but it never falls off.
Uh,
once it's at the brink,
even extremely close to it then comes
back.
Um,
and it retains its unique spirit of
entrepreneurship and innovativeness.
Uh,
Europe needs to,
uh,
begin to harness that and begin to
belief in its own ability to be
entrepreneurial,
creative,
and innovative,
uh,
and to believe in itself.
So far it hasn't done that.
It's still always eyeing towards the
United States.
Um,
I think a little bit more self
confidence would do it good.